I'm here with Mark field CEO Ford great
to see your presentation this morning
very positive outlook let me first ask
you though before we got to talk about
Ford about Detroit 1201 a.m. this
morning this city comes out of
bankruptcy how exciting is that it's
very exciting I mean this is this is our
home it's really important we have a
healthy southeast Michigan a healthy
Detroit I think it's just another piece
of evidence of the positive momentum
that's building in the city and in the
area it's is very very exciting and what
one of the things you guys are talking
about today is your new initiative with
TechStars kind of figuring out mobility
for the future bringing it here to
Detroit I was talking with Bill Ford
about it earlier how do you balance kind
of bored looking for solutions to
traffic for participating in the sharing
economy and at the same time selling
more cars they seem to be almost at odds
those two two things well if you go back
to our founder Henry Ford he was all
about making people's lives better and
finding solutions to things so as we
look at the business of course we have
our traditional business selling cars
and trucks but we're thinking more more
of ourselves also as a mobility company
and how do we provide you know
transportation solutions for folks so
we're looking at the trends people want
to be mobile particularly in urban areas
we want to be part of the solution we're
not looking at it as a threat we're
looking at it as an opportunity and some
things we'll build ourselves some things
will buy to help us to do this and some
things will partner with and that's the
way we're looking at it so do you think
there's gonna be a lot more partnering
is there gonna be a lot more cooperation
in the auto industry well I think
overall when you look at mobility going
forward there is going to be an
increased level of cooperation not only
I think among different competitors but
as you choose partners maybe traditional
partners non-traditional partners to
focus on solutions partnering with the
government's for infrastructure so
public-private partnerships so it's all
about working together to provide these
solutions particularly in congested
urban areas
it's an acquire all of us to work
together and at the same time make sure
that there's a business model and a
benefit for those of us that are that
are that are participating that and a
great solution for customers all right
so the future is bright obviously high
tech and really cool if you talk about
though the now and today your bread and
butter the Ford f-150 I'm driving it
today test testing it out what's your
outlook for this for this you know a lot
of people are saying game changer for
this truck well our new f-150 i'm a bit
biased but it's a technological marvel
and it really we feel is going to change
the industry we're seeing some
reverberations of that right now we're
shipping the vehicles the initial
consumer response is terrific and we're
basically changing the definition of
built ford tough it's it's it's the
strongest most capable vehicle we've
ever put in the marketplace using
technology to solve problems for
customers and that's giving them a more
capable truck and a truck that's gonna
be very fuel efficient so I'm in you
know I'm in my Raptor 2014 rapture I'm
kind of a lead foot i get like 13 miles
a gallon are you gonna get people to
shift up to this more fuel-efficient
truck you're more fuel-efficient
vehicles with gas prices at two dollars
and ninety cents well it's a great
question because when you look across
literally all the segments people still
want great fuel economy you know they
want it they want to make sure their
dollars are stretching further and right
now gas prices are coming down so it's
putting more money in folks pockets but
I think consumers are a lot more smarter
these days they know that gas prices can
go down they could go up and they want
to make sure the vehicles that they're
buying that they're getting the very
best fuel economy and that's why we're
taking the approach with the f-150 and
all of our vehicle lines so they know
that Ford fuel economy is a reason to
buy you know a big picture if you step
back and look at cheaper gas prices have
to get people i would think out to buy
new cars because it's less expensive to
run them how does it though affect your
whole industry to see oil coming down
this sharply this quickly well i think
to your point it is a it's
it's a bonus for all the consumers out
there it immediately it's almost like an
immediate tax cut it puts more money in
their pockets you know clearly we think
that will stimulate the economy will
have a benefit in the auto industry so
we're looking at that as an opportunity
but also at the same time not taking our
eye off the fact that we shouldn't get
diluted by oh well fuel economy is not
important to consumers going forward it
will be because when we provide that
solution they'll get better fuel economy
and they'll get more money in their
pockets so they can do what they want
whether it's send their kids to college
or buy more things for themselves will
it help the situation in Europe I mean
things look great here in the US over in
Europe it's a different story even if
the industry kind of bounces back Ford
still projecting losses for next year
well when you look at Europe clearly
with as we're seeing here in the US
depending upon the study you see the
drop in gas prices could add two three
even four tenths of percentage points of
gdp we think it will be helpful in
Europe because again it is a it goes
right to the bottom line of folks but
clearly the market in Europe is still
it's still challenge we do see growth
this year minimally our projection for
next year is a bit more growth but we
have to watch it very closely because
it's been plateauing of it what can you
do differently I mean you're sending
Farley over there I know Jim parlays
gonna go and run your division there
what can for do differently to try and
beat out competitors with this with such
a minimal bounce back well our whole
approach there is implementing what we
call our transformation plan out there
and it's around building our brand it's
around introducing a full family of
products and we're doing that and
particularly see you these and small s
you'd small and medium-sized SUVs
because that segment is growing wildly
there and we it's a sweet spot for us as
a company and then finally working on
costs so we're gonna continue to work
our plan their continue to look at the
business environment and make sure we're
doing the right things to get the
business back to profitability how do
you feel about the situation in Russia I
mean you've you've been all over the
globe just to remind people you know
you've run things in Europe you've been
in Asia what do you think when something
like this happens
the global turmoil and I just noticed
you you're opening a third plant with a
joint venture in Russia I mean it seems
like a strange difficult time to expand
their well even in the most difficult
times and Russia is a very difficult
market right now still we have to step
back and when you look at even the the
diminished expectations of the
marketplace it's around to 2.2 million
units that still makes it one of the
biggest markets in Europe and there's
never a bad time to introduce great
product into a marketplace so the plant
that we're just opening is introducing
our EcoSport which is a small SUV
perfectly suited for the Russian market
place and we want to serve our Russian
customers so as we look at that business
there we want to make sure we're dealing
with the business environment continuing
to work our plan work our way through it
play through it because we think it's
it's an important market and will be
important market going forward I want to
finally ask you about the cicadas
situation here we talked about it last
time I was in Detroit will you continue
to work with Takata will you recall all
of the vehicles that are equipped with
the faulty airbags what do you think
about the supplier well we've been we've
been working with nitsa on and taking
the appropriate actions because you know
for us very simply the safety of our
customers is of the utmost importance so
we're working with its on that and you
know we're continuing to work with with
Takata in terms of some of the
technologies as well as working with
some of the other suppliers for those
type of systems in the in the automotive
industry and we'll continue to do that
but will you recall that all the cars
that are equipped with those Takata
airbags well we've recalled all the ones
in the affected areas that nitsa has
asked us to do so and we'll continue to
look at it going forward as we look at
customer experience on that but safety
is very important and will continue to
be proactive on this as we go forward
alright mark thanks so much for spending
time with us appreciated mark fields k
CEO of the ford motor company here in
Detroit